it was the summer of 2012 in damascus
and for the people of syria
it certainly seemed like all the
predictions about the end of the world
were coming true
the syrian civil war was raging between
multiple rebel groups
and the dictator bashar al-assad whose
government was shelling
its own people as well as using chemical
weapons and brutal campaigns of violence
across the country
in hopes of quelling the rebellion
little did they know
amidst all this pain and bloodshed
something
even more dangerous was brewing an
anomalous phenomenon
in the sunny plains north of damascus
that may pose a threat to
all of humanity someday a threat known
to the scp foundation
as scp-3989
the bone orchard this temporal and
spatial anomaly was discovered a few
years earlier in 2009
before the syrian civil war even
officially began
it's strange for a highly dangerous
ketter class anomaly to be discovered
under such seemingly mundane
circumstances
the scp foundation first became aware of
scp-3989 after a small olive orchard
owner sold a strangely high amount of
olives that shouldn't have been possible
when compared to his reported number of
olea europea olive trees
field agents were dispatched to question
the owner about his sudden success
but he was resistant to questioning the
agents began a covert surveillance
operation
to figure out what was actually going on
here at which point they discovered a
considerable spatial anomaly
the olive orchard was far bigger on the
inside
the property was seized by the
foundation for containment the owner had
no real knowledge of the spatial anomaly
it's likely he just decided not to look
a gift horse in the mouth while making
money hand over fist from the extra
olives he sold
the owner was given amnesics and a new
life as the foundation began to study
this anomaly which was now labeled
scp-3989
to this day no researcher has been able
to figure out the origin of 3989's
anomalous qualities
it was first given a euclid class
designation and cordoned off from the
public with a simple chain-link fence
while foundation investigations were
underway on the inside
on a map the plot of land the olive farm
should occupy
is about five square acres but this plot
contains an
unseen portal to a pocket dimension
within its 12
meter active zone which doesn't follow
the same spatial laws that our reality
does
this subdimension known as scp-3989-a
is a hotbed of fascinating anomalous
activity
upon discovery of this hot zone the
foundation established the nearby area
126 as a research center and a makeshift
containment facility
for any anomalous entities captured from
scp-3989-a
it seemed like the foundation really had
a handle on this situation
but they were blissfully unaware of the
true horrors lurking with an
scp-3989-a but they'd soon find
out in the most horrifying way possible
dr farah gazelli was assigned to head
the research into the anomalous zone
within 3989
and naturally he began organizing
fact-finding expeditions into the heart
of the affected area
the first guinea pig to head into the
hot zone was former foundation agent
josiah herrick
who'd been demoted to the lowly d-class
position of d-126-15
due to failures on a previous mission
with a remote link to dr gazelli
herrick was forced to venture into the
active anomalous zone to collect footage
and samples of the flora and fauna
within
the first thing herrick noticed on his
expedition was the strange quality of
the olive trees within the active zone
the bark was a stark white and the
leaves a bloody red
up close herrick could see that the
trunks and branches of the trees had
undergone a process known as
ossification
where the material slowly becomes bone
or bone-like tissue
hence the anomaly's creepy name the bone
orchard
these ossified trees became known as
scp-3989-1
herrick also made another discovery all
over the trees and ground were worm-like
creatures that looked like
long maggots that the foundation dubbed
scp-3989-1
agent herrick then noticed something was
off about the leaves of the ossified
trees
they were beating he looked closer and
they appeared to be heart tissue
filled with pumping veins dr gazelle
ordered herrick to take a branch for
testing
and when he did the tree began to bleed
when he looked down
he saw that the worm-like creatures that
covered the ground were now crawling up
his legs
ignoring orders from dr gazelli herrick
fled from the active zone
in terror as he left dr gazzelli caught
something in the corner of herrick's
body cam footage
a long white hind limb disappearing
behind a tree
back in our normal dimension tests on
the sample hair collected yielded more
upsetting discoveries
genetically the trees were identical to
humans the trunks were human bone
and the leaves really were made of human
hard tissue
fascinated and just a little bit
horrified dr gazzelli authorized further
expeditions into 3989-a
this time though agent herrick would be
accompanied by another d-class
and both would be armed with handguns
and protective body armor
as it would turn out this expedition
would be even more horrifying than the
first
as the two d-classes explored the active
zones to collect further samples
they found that the worms were
responsible for the ossification of the
otherwise non-anomalous olive trees
they consumed the wood little by little
and deposited human bone matter in
return
herrick and his companion also noticed
that these trees were beginning to bear
fruit
dr gazelli ordered herrick to collect
some of this fruit for testing
but when they attempted to remove the
fruit it burst
releasing more worm creatures it seemed
that the converted trees
acted as incubators for their egg sacs
before the duo could return with the
samples they were able to take
the creature that had been spotted on
herrick's body cam during the first
mission
finally appeared it was huge with long
white limbs and no facial features
except for a
huge mouth it grabbed herrick's
companion and literally ate the top half
of his body in a single bite
before dropping his legs to the ground
this horrifying beast
and the many others like it would later
be designated as
scp-3989-2a
herrick pulled out his sidearm and shot
the creature several times
the creature ignored the bullets though
and charged herrick
the feed from his body cam cut out soon
after
both men were declared killed in action
and in recognition of his sacrifice
josiah herrick was posthumously
reinstated to his old position in the
foundation
job well done agent dr gazelli meanwhile
prepared for the next mission
this time knowing of the clear dangers
present within the bone orchard
dr gazelle recruited the help of mtf
zeta9
aka the mole rats three members
referred to as charlie team were sent
into the anomalous zone
once again remotely directed by dr
gazelli they were equipped with
experimental ultrasound technology
so they could scan the fruit of the
trees within 3989-a without breaking any
and incurring the wrath
of 3989-2a which seemed to act as
sentries for the trees
early on in their journey they found the
body of agent herrick crucified against
one of the ossified trees
his skin covered in mysterious symbols
that were likely of sarkic origin
while we don't have time to fully
explore sarkicism that will require a
video explanation all of its own
all you need to know is that it's a
dangerous religious cult that worships
flesh and disease and has close ties to
similar dangerous anomalies
like scp-610 also known as the flesh
that hates
people familiar with that scp will note
eerily strange similarities to some of
the things the mole rats were about to
encounter
as charlie team explored they saw a huge
number of 39
89 2as observing them with eyeless faces
from between the ossified trees
they pressed on until they discovered
what seemed to be an entirely new kind
of tree within the bone orchard
scp-3989-2 were huge
trees made out of what appears to be
enlarged human spines in place of a
trunk
the smaller twigs on the tree were made
from heart and lung tissue
and the whole thing was covered in what
appeared to be human amniotic sacs
charlie team attempted to use their
ultrasound scanners to discover the
contents of these sacks but one of them
exploded in the process
releasing an entirely new variety of
monster
from the sacks emerged the larval stage
of scp-3989-2b
smaller humanoid monsters with no faces
no sensory organs two pelvises
four legs and an exposed spine suddenly
charlie team could feel a horrifying
sarkic presence around them
which one member of the team described
as being like someone grabbing her liver
and giggling in her face
as the various monsters of the bone
orchard began to converge on the team
the voice of the sarkic prophet of war
and the hunt
began sounding in their ears he was
beckoning them
to join him while charlie team fled from
the active zone
dr ghazali felt increasingly drawn into
it
he heard the voice of orok and he liked
what he heard
little by little the workers of area 126
were losing their minds
manipulated by the sarkic power of the
bone orchard right next to them
day after day they were no longer loyal
to the foundation
they wanted to serve their new dark
masters
the fourth and final expedition was led
by dr gazelli himself
he took a band of loyal followers and
one non-believer
on a quest into the active zone to find
an orkian temple
they believed was hidden in the very
heart of the bone orchard
once they were inside gazelle and his
loyalists murdered the non-believer as a
sacrifice to their new master
they carried on until they eventually
found what they were looking for
a giant stone temple resembling an aztec
ziggurat dubbed scp-3989-4
there they also encountered a new kind
of monster dubbed scp-3989-3
these beasts were larger than the others
and resembled ancient warriors
they had insect-like exoskeletal armor
horned heads
additional hind and forelimbs and
integrated bladed weapons
what dr ghazali and his companions
thought would be paradise
turned out to be a kind of hell as they
were led into the temple
where temporal and spatial distortions
broke their mind
and the multiple highly aggressive
instances of scp-3989-3-2-a
and d-2b broke their bodies the whole
thing had been a
horrifying trap in that moment back at
area 126
another fleshy horrifying tree sprouted
out of the ground
in the middle of the complex monsters
that had once been dr gazelli and his
followers emerged from its amniotic sacs
and all hell broke loose throughout the
complex
soon enough the base was crawling with
monsters from the bone orchard and staff
who'd become brainwashed sarkic cultists
working in service of orok
humans were gathered up to be sacrificed
to the ever-growing number of anomalous
trees
things came to a head when the anomaly
in area 126 was visited by an outside
agent from the foundation
working on behalf of the hazardous
materials containment liaison
biological containment specialist dr
marshall grant and his team
arrived at the site and were horrified
to see the sarkic nightmare that had
unfolded
they quickly engaged in a firefight with
the anomalous creatures and sarkic
devotees who'd gained control over area
126
a number of dr grant's team were lost in
the process
but thankfully they were able to
eventually regain control of the base
and the anomalous area after this
incident scp-3989 was upgraded to ketter
class
and given a huge upgrade in security
including four meter high
concrete walls and a platoon sized
regiment of mobile task force members
with heavy weaponry
the force that took over the minds of
those exposed was designated
scp-3989-5
a force so powerful that those infected
are given the choice to self-terminate
or be contained forever this may seem
like a somewhat happy ending to a grim
tale but one detail keeps dr grant and
everyone at the foundation
who is forced to deal with 3989 awake at
night
according to all recent studies into the
bone orchard
it isn't contained at all in fact the
active zone
is getting bigger now go check out
scp-4000 taboo
and scp-5545 abnormality for more
strange
nightmare locations from the scp
foundation